ja mein thema ist heute
antisemitismus in deutschland wachsenden
antisemitismus und ich und meine
mitstreiter in hamburg die einmal im
monat die mahnwache für israel gegen
antisemitismus machen sind der meinung
das ist untragbar ist dass in
deutschland wieder der antisemitismus
wächst von rechts von links aber auch
von muslimischer seite dass die
politiker viel erzählen und spiel
ständig hören wir müssen gegen
antisemitismus etwas unternehmen aber
dann wären zum beispiel diese wirklich
israel-feindlichen sogenannten nakba
demonstrationen erlaubt in berlin wurde
sie jetzt letztes wochenende verboten in
hamburg hat sie stattgefunden und in
anderen städten auch zum beispiel hat in
frankfurt die jüdische gemeinde sich
also flehentlich an die behörden
gewendeten hat gesagt bitte unterbinden
sie diese israel-feindlichen
veranstaltung wo also gegen israel und
nicht nur an die nakba den sogenannten
die vertreibung von von arabern 1948
erinnert wird sondern der staat israel
delegitimiert wird wo zu hass gegen
juden aufgerufen wird et cetera et
cetera und
wir sagen es reicht nicht nur
sich aufzuregen sondern wir sagen man
muss auf die straße gehen wir müssen in
deutschland ein zeichen setzen und wir
müssen schlage zeigen das machen wir mit
unserem mahnwache für israel einmal im
monat und
wie sehen da die bilder das ist zum
beispiel von einem veranstaltungen die
wir in hamburg hatten und sie haben
darüber berichtet
hier war bild tv letztes jahr wir sind
attackiert worden mit einem
schwerverletzten von muslimen wir haben
jetzt letztes wochenende gegen den
aufmarsch von
von arabern bei dieser demo
protestiert ich bin bedroht worden von
dem veranstalter und von teilnehmern die
ein nachbar demonstration und stadt man
den veranstalter und die teilnehmer zur
räson bringt hat man mich sozusagen ja
mit aller gewalt wir sehen dass auf den
bildern an die an die an das fenster
dargestellt
ist ging mich vorgegangen hat mich eine
halbe stunde dort festgehalten und ich
denke das ist unmöglich hier wird also
recht umgekehrt aber herr müller wie ist
das möglich sie haben ja danach
wahrscheinlich als sie sich die
situation beruhigt hat haben sie ja
wahrscheinlich versucht herauszufinden
warum sie dort dermaßen festgehalten
wurden nein es wurde ja keine begründung
gegeben also ist wurde ich wohl
beschimpft von seiten des veranstalters
dieser demonstration die dort in der
mönckebergstraße stadt fahren und
sofort haben acht beamte sich auf mich
gestürzt ich wurde also sehr rabiat
abgeführt es wurde mir angedroht mich zu
boden zu werfen wenn ich mich wäre weil
ich gesagt habe was habe ich getan ich
werde bedroht es gab ja auch zeugen es
gab ja zahlreiche zeugen die das
mitbekommen haben und
mir wurde gar keine gelegenheit gegeben
das zu erklären sondern ich wurde dort
also sehr
unsanft
aus dem verkehr gezogen und übrigens
dann auch das feldes verwiesen also
platzverweis heißt das
nach einer halben stunde es gab eine
kleine gegendemo
dort ein paar meter weiter weg die
wollten wir dann besuchen das wurde mir
verwehrt und man hat gesagt nein sie
müssen gehen verlassen sie den platz und
dann wurde ich raus eskortiert von dem
wagen sie sagen die polizei darf nicht
die täter schützen wie ist es bei den
medien schützen die zu sehr die täter
weil sie auch oft die täter nicht direkt
ansprechen
wenn du mal ein bisschen vorsichtig die
medien
selbst
nein es gibt solche und solche natürlich
das wissen sie genau so es gibt nicht
die guten oder die bösen medien sondern
es gibt medien die sich damit
beschäftigen und es gibt medien die
bestimmte sachverhalte ausblenden und
das ist bei den printmedien so und die
über die muss man nämlich auch reden das
ist bei den
bei den anderen medien visuellen medien
auch so es gibt man kann nicht sagen die
medien sind schuld aber es gibt schon
finde ich also eine eine grundhaltung
die ein bisschen schwierig ist also da
wo antisemitismus klar zuzuordnen ist zu
nazis zu rechtsextremisten da ist jeder
sich in der verurteilung absolut einig
und da ist die auch ganz schnell da ist
ja völlig richtig so mit dem
islamistischen antisemitismus ist es
tatsächlich anscheinend eine andere
sache und das ist glaube ich bei der mir
sehr oft wird er wird nur sagen hat und
es hat sich an ähnlichen fall auch in
berlin gegeben so kann man im bild
kollegen wo es eben auch sowas der
berichterstatter dann der wiesn wurde
statt sozusagen mal gegen den
aggressiven veranstalter vorzugehen weiß
der himmel was die polizei da nun für
motive haben mag dass werden interessant
wenn sie individuell auch gegen die
beamten vorgehen was was man tun sollte
da nicht aber es gibt auch bei den
berichterstattern glaube ich die angst
also ich will kein rassist zu sein und
wenn ich also sagen es gibt eben auch
den islamistischen antisemitismus dann
habe ich natürlich also kann ich leicht
in seinem fahrwasser geraten aber du
bist jetzt einfach hier generell gegen
muslime das ist natürlich bullshit darum
geht es überhaupt nicht es geht um eine
bestimmte sozusagen politisch
aufgeladene radikale islamistische welt
sich die fundamental antisemitisch und
haben
eigene geschichte dass wir vielleicht
aber da müsste ja erst recht so zu sagen
das wäre ja eigentlich auch sensibel
sein was uns wirklich schützend vor
juden stellen es ist auch also sagen mir
jüdische freunde extrem ärgerlich immer
wenn es dann mal ein attentat gegeben
hat einen übergriff irgendwas schlimmes
passiert ist dann stehen sie da relativ
alleine demonstrieren also so viele
leute kommen dann nicht mit sozusagen
vor allem von anderen glaubensrichtungen
oder oder auf der atheistischen
gesellschaft also sondern das ist dann
eben ihr jüdisches problem jetzt ist
nicht so das kann man sich ja nicht
sagen dass jetzt alle nun hier schon auf
gepackten koffern saßen aber also die
jüdischen freunde die ich habe leiden
schon unter einer verschärften stimmung
also die sind nicht entspannt und die
sind nicht völlig die haben auch nicht
das gefühl dass wir als gesellschaft
also an ihrer seite stehen wie wir das
müssen die jungen häufig ein problem mit
der richtung woher und wie müssen sie
das ist ja das problem sie haben es
richtig angesprochen wenn sie sich frau
feser zum beispiel mit ihren
stellungnahmen und
und dem was sie verlautbaren lässt
angucken es geht immer um rechts rechts
die gefahr von rechts ich mache diese
mahnwache für israel seit sieben jahren
seit sieben jahren stehen wir dort
mindestens einmal auf der straße im
monat und es kommen von deutschen
natürlich mal blöde sprüche aber in
diesen sieben jahren haben wir mehrmals
polizeischutz bekommen weil wir von
muslimen das ist keine generalisierung
sondern es sind halt überwiegend muslime
die uns attackieren
letztes jahr das waren
menschen mit junge leute mit syrischem
hintergrund ich meine es ist es geht
auch hier nicht um einen generalverdacht
man kann doch nicht sagen wenn jemand
jemand umbringt dann dürfen wir das
nicht aufdecken weil 100000 haben keinen
umgebracht das ist doch quatsch man muss
die probleme benennen und wir haben ein
neues problem von muslimischer seite und
ich sage und ich sage es nochmal wir
machen diese unsere mahnwache in
verbindung wir haben persische leute
kommen aus dem islam die neben dran
stehen dies sind muslime aber die haben
kein problem mit israel und die haben
vor allen dingen auch kein problem mit
mit juden und das ist genau das das ist
genau der punkt aber seien wir
eigentlich selber schön dass es die auch
gibt ja also das ist also das ist doch
eigentlich ein gutes beispiel ist doch
eigentlich sehr positiv dass da auch
menschen aus dem iran stehen und mit
ihnen zusammen demonstrieren das
anerkennen also ich finde das eigentlich
er diesen teil sehr positiv natürlich
sehr positiv und sie unseren und
nächstes auf rechnet man kann nicht das
eine gegen das andere
natürlich eine frage an sie sie haben ja
auch in london studiert wie haben sie
das da war genau sie haben in
verschiedenen ländern gelebt wie haben
sie es dort wagen im unterschied zu
deutschland also ich finde in england
hat man sehr andere
sichtweise auf das ganze thema wie sich
andere kulturen integrieren also es gibt
zum beispiel ganz viele polizisten die
six sind das ist ein
stamm verso s ist eine volksgruppe aus
indien die sind nicht hinter sondern
eine eigene religionsgruppe und die sind
ganz häufig polizisten das ist aber
deshalb möglich weil sie erlaubt sind
ihren kopfschmuck zu tragen dann trägt
man das als polizist halt ja in london
ist das viel eher so dass man sagt du
kannst ein region mitbringen aber so
integriert und dann haben wir auch sechs
die polizisten sind zum beispiel und das
finde ich eigentlich sehr positiv wie
multikulturalismus funktionieren kann
eine england gibt es eine große ignoranz
gegenüber dem holocaust und und
gegenüber der israel frage das muss man
auch sagen also ich glaube england hat
auch ein massives bildungsproblem
entwickelt in den letzten jahren also zu
sagen ich weiß nicht wie gut die
allgemeinbildung über europäische
kontinentaleuropäische geschichte da zum
teil ist und ich meine gerade die labour
party das war ja besonders erschütternd
und der ehemalige vorsitzende mit kabine
hat sich also durch durch also bruse
ignoranz zumindest da ist ja noch mal
konnte sie das jetzt die dörfer genauen
haben wir natürlich auch klar herr
müller landen denn hier in deutschland
genug fälle vor gericht
auch ich finde erst mal landen fälle vor
gericht wenn es aufgeklärt wird man die
polizei vor ort genau schaut denn dann
auch fälle vor gericht welche fälle von
polizeigewalt oder fälle von
angreifen antisemitischen äußerungen
fälle von verwenden
verfassungsfeindlicher kennzeichen
hier wird schon gemacht aber ich sehe im
moment so nicht das große problem da ja
ich seh tatsächlich weiß wenn in berlin
man hinschaute sind
ja natürlich habe der jahrelang gegen
gekämpft legendäre sind meine taten hin
rechtsradikale schläger ich bin auch im
jüdischen zeitung erwähnt worden oder
ganze berichte darüber gegen
antisemitismus aber
das ist ein problem es waren probleme
und es wird auch natürlich es muss
angegangen werden klar und es muss
verhindert werden und ich habe solche
fälle dass leute sollten jugendliche
juden sind an einem schuld und die
wissen ja dass ein jude ist usw da muss
gelernt werden aber ich sehe trotzdem im
großen und ganzen ich finde unsere stadt
ganz gut ja ich finde unser grundgesetz
ganz gut trotz die trotz des umstands
soll sich alles richtig ist wie bei der
journalistische
müller haben
wir müssen zum anderen thema kommen
jeder der sein letztes es ganz gut aber
finden sie es gut dass juden in
deutschland
wir haben in berlin die fälle gehabt
dass juden keine keepers tragen darf ich
das allen lebens gefahren und wir können
doch nicht sagen dass
solche täter vorgegangen meinen hier